I'll never forget it was like when the
first SpaceX rocket took the first batch
of satellites up all of a sudden the
astronomers were like hey this is going
to hurt our field I couldn't believe I
mean I'd been following this as a semi
casual Observer for years was like this
was not like a secret you know I mean
this was on a a launch manifest for a
really long time I found it to be a very
strange time to begin complaining about
this and trying to sound the alarm
because these days are over I would
argue you know astronomers and
scientists if they're going to find sort
of the blessing in all this is that the
price to get a scientific instrument
into space and to put it further into
space is going to be so much lower than
ever before that maybe there's like sort
of a boon to science that can be done in
that you have much better access than
you have before